try new stuff can be painful can be  comfort zone break and it should be it's  new it's variety it's different you're  going to stumble you're gonna fail you  might get embarrassed that's part of the  process otherwise you photocop your life  and it's just the same day over and over  and over and over again and you hate  your life We crave variety you need it  but it's painful to go off and do new  things because you risk judgment  embarrassment failure but on the other  end of that is regret  if you don't go off and do the thing you  will regret it for the rest of your life  do you want this current left that  you're living right now for the rest of  your life yes amazing you want more you  have to go chase it down